hello and welcome to the very first
episode of deep dive the brand new
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophy strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning so that was the intro for
the new podcast that we're launching
welcome to deep dive whether you are
watching this on the youtube channel or
listening to this on a podcast app it is
lovely to see you if you don't know me
then hi my name is ali i'm a doctor
youtuber and podcaster currently living
in london and this podcast has been a
long-term ambition dream of mine to have
a sort of podcast where i've basically
got an excuse to have a long form
conversation with people who i admire
and the cool thing about a podcast like
this is that we can really showcase
other people's expertise and other
people's journeys for the last four
years since 2017 i've been making videos
on youtube about how to live a healthier
happier more productive life and it's
been mostly sharing my own personal
experience but also the experience of
authors through books and book summaries
and all that kind of stuff if you're not
familiar with my main channel there will
be a link in the video description and
then the show notes all that fun stuff
but the really cool thing about a
podcast is that i can now have these
conversations with people from all
around the world who are thriving in
their fields whether it be
entrepreneurialism or creatorism or i
don't know just other cool cool kind of
stuff and in particular i'm very
interested in how these cool people find
fulfillment in work and in life and so
we've got a lot of interviews with
entrepreneurs who made it like really
successful by society's traditional
definitions of success and we kind of
dive into what their early days were
like how they set up a company like
gymshark or my protein how they how they
got it off the ground how they kept
themselves motivated in the early days
when nothing seemed to be working how
they made it fun for themselves along
the way the successes along the way the
failures along the way what they learned
from that journey and how they're
thinking about what they're doing with
their lives moving forward often the
people that we've interviewed have had
traditional success and in a way like
figuring out what to do with your life
once you've ticked the boxes of societal
success is
an interesting problem as well in
addition to the the thing of getting
something started from the ground up
hopefully the interviews and
conversations will be interesting to
listen to uh and will be inspiring uh at
whatever stage you are of your journey
and certainly they've been inspiring for
me so far the ones that we've done for
season one and hopefully they'll also
have some practical and actionable
advice that you can apply to your own
life as well um one thing i say in the
intro is that we do want to be taking
everything that people say with a little
sprinkle of salt i think it's important
to keep in mind when you listen to a
podcast like this one which is often
based around self-help or advice giving
that you know people like me people like
our guests as successful as the guests
are by societies whatever metrics
society wants to use as successful as
they are they can only really speak to
their own personal experience and
certainly when i speak for my youtube
videos or in this podcast i'm just
sharing my own personal experience and
so it's easy to get into that mindset of
like oh this is this is like solid
advice and this person knows what
they're talking about therefore i should
listen to their advice i think that's
fine but i think when it comes to life
advice it's it's more a case of see what
works for different people and then take
the bits that resonate with you and
apply those to your own life because as
much as we'd like it like there really
is no manual for living a happy and
meaningful life there are certainly you
know evidence-based things that we can
do to help along the way and that's a
lot of the stuff that we're going to be
sharing on the podcast but there's no
clear manual and i think if there was
then life would just be a little bit
boring so that's why i say take
everything that you hear on this podcast
with a little sprinkle of salt to be on
that i hope you find the interviews the
conversations insightful and
entertaining and informative and all
those other adjectives if this sounds
good if you'd like to support the
podcast then really everything is free
um we might have sponsors further down
the line if sponsors want to reach out
to us but basically if you can just like
subscribe to the podcast feed on your
podcast app of choice whether that's
itunes or apple podcast or google
podcast or spotify or wherever you're
listening to this hit the subscribe
button or if you're watching this on our
youtube channel do hit the subscribe
button as well we also have a deep dive
clips youtube channel where we take like
sound bites and snippets from the
conversation and hopefully give them a
good title and thumbnail and put that on
the clips channel because i know
sometimes you know an hour to three hour
long conversation it's hard to make the
time to listen to those sorts of things
even if you do listen to this stuff at
2x speed uh like i sometimes like to do
and so you might like to check out the
deep dive clips channel as well but yeah
thank you so much for watching uh this
or listening to this intro uh hopefully
you'll find the interviews
good and i guess we'll
see you sometime in the podcast feed i
don't really know how to do a podcast
it's all it's all a bit new but it's all
pretty exciting so yeah thanks for
watching slash listening and and see you
later bye